nous faisons étape aujourd'hui dans le
12e arrondissement de paris le député
européen jean marie cavada qui a lâché
françois bayrou fait route avec l'actuel
ministre de l'économie christine lagarde
un arrondissement clé pour l'ump qui
veut reconquérir l'hôtel de ville
florence trintignac yvon bodin
la place de la nation fait tourner la
tête des candidats à la mairie de paris
avec ses 140 mille habitants le 12e
arrondissement mélange de quartier
moderne d'immeubles haussmanniens et de
petites rues commerçantes est un enjeu
pour tous les partis
pour défendre ses couleurs l'ump a
choisi des têtes connues jean marie
cavada
ex-journaliste transfuges du modem et
christine lagarde ministre de l'économie
sans aucune attache dans le xiième ils
doivent ramener à droite cet
arrondissement qui votent désormais au
centre ou à gauche pour y parvenir jean
marie cavada prend ses distances avec le
parti présidentiel
je crois pas que l'aménagement de la
ville soient de droite ou de gauche je
ne crois pas que les crottes de chien
soit du centre-mauges du centre-droit et
je pense par dessus tout que nous sommes
dans des problématiques tellement
compliqué et tellement je dirais urgente
que j'ai cherché à obtenir
deux mois la plus large participation de
gens venant d'horizons politiques divers
je ne suis pas ump laly s'appelle cavada
essence feytiat semaine à quelques rues
le modem et corinne lepage ex ministre
de l'environnement et candidats
atteignent présidentielle ce jour là
françois bayrou est venue la soutenir
l'occasion de régler quelques comptes
avec jean marie cavada son ancienne amie
dans la vie les gens aiment le courage
et la fidélité aux idées delà de ces
querelles corinne lepage doit convaincre
qu'elle n'a pas été par insulter dans
cet arrondissement où il n'a dit pas
c'est l'équipe du modem 12 qui a voulu
que je sois leur taper dessus ils ont
délibérément ils ont été recherchées et
donc c'est pas du tout un choix duo qui
a décidé que j'allais venir ici c'est un
choix du bas qui a décidé qu'il voulait
que je sois leur tête de lit un peu à
l'écart l'actuel maire ps michèle
blumenthal candidate à sa propre
succession pour se démarquer le mène une
campagne discrète ces arguments son
ancrage dans le xiième et sa proximité
avec ses administrés je ne suis pas
concerné ça je ne sais pas fait terminée
c'est pas
la journée à la télévision je suis une
amie shine event and mr du 12ème et ivre
cya fort de son bilan dans le xiième les
enjeux s'entrechoquent scrutin décisif
pour la bataille de paris
l'arrondissement est aussi le lieu
d'affrontements politiques nationaux